privatinsolvenz und er hat uns unsere
zuschauerinnen sabine karrenbauer aus
saarbrücken ein handy video geschickt
meine frage ist am gegen fachmann
ich war vor drei jahren in
privatinsolvenz und unserer
eigentumswohnung hatten wir müssen eher
verkaufen findet ist versteigert worden
das bin ich seit über drei jahren
füllten frei und aber was mich die ganze
zeit betrübt ob meine negativen schufa
eintragungen von alleine lösen oder ob
ich das machen wir erstmal hut ab frau
karrenbauer nicht jeder spricht über so
ein heikles thema so offen wie sie ein
harter tobak privatinsolvenz wie sehen
sie den fall herr kempkens ja dass ich
finde es auch gut wenn man öffentlich
darüber spricht denn da kann man sich
auch austauschen man kann sich auch mit
anderen personen austauschen was kann
helfen was kann ich machen was den
schufa eintrag anbelangt der wird also
nach dieser restschuldbefreiung oder
beendigung des verfahrens bleibt der
drei jahre drin da steht natürlich drin
dass es inzwischen erledigt ist dass die
restschuldbefreiung erfolgt ist aber
dieser eintrag bei drei jahre drin
und dieser eintrag wird dann automatisch
gelöscht man muss also keine anträge
stellen wenn man sehen will was in der
schufa notiert ist dann kann man einmal
im jahr kostenlos dort einen antrag
stellen und über sich selbst eine
auskunft einholen und da kann man eben
sehen was los ist und da ist natürlich
auch ganz wichtig natürlich bietet die
schufa auch kostenpflichtige dienste an
muss aber alles nicht sein der stichwort
ist kostenlose daten kopie und dann gibt
es wie in kempten satz gesagt hat alles
kostenlose sie sehen was da
abgespeichert ist und tatsächlich haben
wir auch in dieser sendung geklärt
tatsächlich wird das tag genau gelöscht
so zu sagen und ich muss in der regel da
nicht hinterherlaufen und darauf achten
ob meine schufa eintrag gelöscht aber
trotzdem schwieriges thema immerhin 6,6
millionen leute haben mindestens einen
negativen schufa-eintrag